بتاعه وزير الدفاع لشؤون الشرق الاوسط
دانسترول ارحب بك على شاشات الجزيره
تغادرين في رحله مع وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
في جوله الى الشرق الاوسط تحديدا الى
الاردن ومصر واسرائيل ما الغايه من هذه
الزياره وما هي الاهداف المحدده التي يود
وزير الدفاع ان يحققها من وراء هذه
الزياره
شكرا لاستضافه ويسرني ان نلتقي مجددا
سيقوم الوزير اوستن بزياره الى اسرائيل
والاردن ومصر وعلى راس اولوياته ان يجدد
لشركائنا الاستراتيجيين الاساسيين ويؤكد
لهم التزام الولايات المتحده الراسخه بدفع
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه قدما وبتعزيز امنهم
سيكون هناك استعراض للشراكات التي يبلغ
عمرها عقودا من الزمن مع هذه الدول وكذلك
لسهول التعاون والتشاور لمواجهه التهديدات
في المنطقه وعلى مستوى العالم وعلى راسها
طبعا ايران وانشطتها المزعزعه للاستقرار
في عموم المنطقه والتهديد العالمي الحالي
الذي تمثله بسبب تعميقها التعاون مع روسيا
اولويه اخرى بطبيعه الحال هي توترات
المتصاعده في الضفه الغربيه وكيف يمكن ان
نتعاون لخفض التصعيد واخيرا سيتحدث الوزير
اوستن مع جميع شركائنا عن كيفيه تعزيز
التعاون الجماعي وزياده التشغيل قواتنا
المسلحه ودمج قدراتنا الدفاعيه التي نعتقد
انها اهم وسيله للدفاع الدائم كما سيلتقي
وزير الدفاع القوات الامريكيه في عدد من
هذه الدول الولايات المتحده تحافظ على
اكثر من 30 الف جندي في الشرق الاوسط وهذه
القوات تعمل يوميا لحمايه الشعب الامريكي
ومواطني واراضي شركائنا
الاستراتيجيينز
السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل صرح اخيرا بان
اسرائيل قادره وينبغي ان تقوم بكل ما
تحتاجه للتعامل مع ايران وبان الولايات
المتحده سوف تساندها في ذلك هل هذه رساله
رسميه يحملها وزير الدفاع الامريكي الى
اسرائيل وهل هذا يعني ان هناك ضوء اخضر
امريكي الان لاسرائيل لكي توجه ضربه
عسكريه لايران للتعامل مع برنامجها النووي
ما سيسمعه اصدقاؤنا ونظراؤنا الاسرائيليون
من الوزير اوستن هو ان التزامنا بامن
اسرائيل راسخ وسنواصل البحث عن فرص لتعزيز
تعاوننا العسكري مع اسرائيل للدفاع عن
ارضها وشعبها وايضا لاننا نعتقد ان
علاقتنا الدفاعيه ثنائيه وتعاون قواتنا
مهمان لبقيه المنطقه ويساهمان في الامن
والاستقرار الاقليميين سيتشاور الوزير
طبعا مع نظرائنا الاسرائيليين حول تهديدات
ايران ليس فقط خطواتها النوويه الخطيره
والتقدم في برنامجها النووي وانما ايضا
حول جميع الانشطه الاخرى المزعزعه
للاستقرار التي تثير قلقا عميقا لدى جميع
شركائنا في الشرق الاوسط سواء عدوانيه
ايران في البحر ورعايتها وتمويلها
وتسليحها وتجهيزها لمجموعات غير تابعه
للدول والوكلاء عنيفين
السيبرانيه والجويه من خلال ترساناتها من
الصواريخ الباليستيه ومسيراتها الانتحاريه
كما اشرتي وزير الدفاع سوف يتشاور مع
القيادات في اسرائيل حول الخطوات لمواجهه
البرنامج النووي الايراني هل هذا يعني ان
هناك بحث في الخيارات العسكريه خلال هذه
الزياره لمواجهه ايران تحديدا فيما يتعلق
بالبرنامج النووي
من المهم ان تدرك شعوب المنطقه واسرائيل
ان الدبلوماسيه هي الوسيله الافضل
للولايات المتحده للتعامل مع برنامج ايران
النووي لكن وظيفه وزاره الدفاع ودور وزير
الدفاع هما توفير خيارات عسكريه موثوقه في
حال طلبها الرئيس مره اخرى اود ان اكون
شديده الوضوح القوه العسكريه هي خيارنا
الاخير وليست على خياراتنا المفضله لكن في
هذه اللحظه نحن قلقون من جميع انشطه ايران
المزعزعه للاستقرار لا سيما تعاونها
العسكري المتزايد مع روسيا وهذه مسائل
ستبحث وسيتشاور الوزير اوستن بشانها مع
جميع نظرائه خلال زيارته للمنطقه رئيس
بايدن كما ان ادارته تفضل الخيار
الدبلوماسي للتعامل مع برنامج ايران
النووي لكن وكيل وزير الدفاع الدكتور
كونكال ابلغ الكونغرس اخيرا بان ايران
يمكنها خلال 12 يوما ان تنتج ما يكفي من
اليورانيوم المخصب لقنبله نوويه واحده الا
يعني هذا ان الخيار الدبلوماسي بات غير
مطروح على الطاوله وبان حتى الخيار
العسكري قد لا يكون ناجحا مع ايران
لم يفوت اوان الدبلوماسيه ولا شك ان تاريخ
الانخراط مع ايران وفيما يتعلق بقضايا
دوليه شائكه فان الدبلوماسيه ستنجح عندما
يكون هناك موقف دولي موحد لمعالجه مشكله
ما اضافه الى التوافق الدولي على استخدام
العقوبات والضغط الاقتصادي لفرض اثمان
وعواقب على ايران جراء برنامجها النووي
الخطير فيما يتعلق بتصريحات الدكتور كارل
ينبغي ان نفهم انها دعوه لاتخاذ اجراءات
في المنطقه ونعني بذلك زياده الضغط على
ايران لتغيير سلوكها والمسار الدبلوماسي
سيظل مفتوحا على الدوام والمفاوضات هي
الوسيله الافضل للتعامل مع الملف النووي
على المدى البعيد لصالح جميع شعوب وحكومات
المنطقه
تحدثت اكثر من مره عن عواقب التعاون
العسكريه الحالي بين ايران وروسيا في
الحرب في اوكرانيا واشرت الى مخاطر على
المنطقه هل يمكن ان تكوني اكثر تحديدا ما
الذي تعنيه بهذه المخاطر والعواقب
هناك تهديد محدد يثير المخاوف في واشنطن
وعلى مستوى العالم يتعلق بنقل المسيرات
الانتحاريه الايرانيه الى روسيا ونحن
نلاحظ ان الروس يستخدمون المسيرات
الهجوميه الايرانيه لاستهداف البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه الاوكرانيه وقطاع الطاقه
وازهاق ارواح المدنيين ما يقلقنا هو ان
ايران وقادتها العسكريين سوف يستخلصون
دروسا مهمه ستزيد من القدرات الفتاكه لهذه
الاسلحه وتطورها وهذه الاسلحه سيعاد
استخدامها وستكون فعاله اكثر وتزيد
تهديدات لشعوب واراضي شركاء الولايات
المتحده في الشرق الاوسط كما راينا تق
صحفيه حول التفكير باقامه منشات ايرانيه
لانتاج عتاد داخل روسيا اضافه الى تقارير
حول مبيعات طائرات حربيه روسيه لايران وكل
هذه الامور تزيد من التهديدات العسكريه في
المنطقه وهذا التعاون المتزايد بين روسيا
وايران والنفوذ الذي تمنحه روسيا لها لن
يؤديها الا الى زياده عدوانيتها
وتكتيكاتها القصريه ضد شركاء الولايات
المتحده في المنطقه
نائبه مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه للشرق
الاوسط دانس رول شكرا مره اخرى لهذه
الفرصه واتمنى لك رحله ناجحه للشرق الاوسط
شكرا لاستضافتي